a lot of people were excited to learn
this year's tax deadline was extended
but
in today's conversation with money coach
lisa chastain
she says that's not necessarily a good
thing for everyone
lisa tax season is upon us and for
procrastinators everywhere
there's immediately some good news
there's some good news kendall and
i wasn't aware of this until recently
also so if you're not aware of this it's
okay but what you want to know is that
the tax filing deadline for 2020 has
been extended
not to july like it was last year but to
may 17th so that's great news for those
of you who have waited until the last
minute you have a little bit more time
but now it's time to get to get your
ducks in a row and get
heading toward filing which is may 17th
deadline
a lot of people are happy because they
get a refund
so when tax season rolls around they
don't procrastinate because they're
going to get a check
but that's not always a great thing
right it's not always a great thing
i have a lot of clients who celebrate
when they get their refund
and some of my clients this year got
pretty sizable refunds
but here's what you want to know a
refund if you get a big refund
it usually means that you've lent the
government
money with interest without interest so
they're holding on to your money because
you've
overpaid and you're getting a refund
for the money that you were paying
forward basically
for the year so pay attention to that
and we know 2020 is done you can't
change that situation now but for 2021
work with your tax planner now or right
after you filed for 2020
to make sure that you're not overpaying
in taxes you really don't want to owe a
lot
but you don't want to get a big refund
either you want to hit right at that
zero if possible
yes you know planning for 2021 it's
important to know all the rules
and some of them are changing there have
been some big changes in particular with
the
child tax credits now i want you to know
the difference between a refund
and a credit a refund like i said
typically means that you've
overpaid but there are some credits that
could come back to you
and it feels like you're getting a
refund and a child tax credit
is one of those so for example last year
the child tax credit
was two thousand dollars for every child
you were claiming as a dependent
and this year it's going up to almost
thirty six hundred dollars so that's a
big difference you could see that
money back when you file in 2021
also there's a child and dependent care
tax credit
where if you are caring for children and
paying for that out of your pocket
you could be getting a tax credit for
that last year for 2020
it was 35 that you would get back up to
3 000
the big change for 2021 is now it's 50
up to 8 000 so that could also make a
big difference for families
in 2021 yeah those are some good changes
lisa thanks so much i always appreciate
your time
thanks kendall and you can get more
financial tips by visiting
lisachastain.com